in what can't possibly be good news for
anybody in the white house Christopher
Steele that former mi6 agent who
prepared what's now known as the Trump
Russia blackmail dossier
he has been approached about testifying
before the US Senate intelligence
committees investigation into president
Trump's alleged links with Russia as
reported by the independent it's not
hugely likely that Christopher Steele
has much of an interest in coming to
Washington DC to testify his friends are
saying it is unlikely he would be
willing to do this it's understood that
Democrats as well as some Republicans in
Congress are prepared to facilitate some
discreet initial meetings with
Christopher Steele in the UK or maybe on
neutral territory he has not yet
responded to requests to meet with the
Senate officials but what we learned
several weeks ago is that Christopher
Steele left his home was essentially
hiding his family for fear for their
safety and his own and when you have
circumstances like the ones we have the
Trump administration possibly completely
in bed with Russia
I don't blame Christopher Steele for his
reluctance to want to come to Washington
DC who knows what would happen if he
stepped foot on US soil perhaps yes I
mean we'll have to see if his feeling of
duty to justice I guess yes to America
will make him want to you know change
this decision but that's totally his to
make as I was reading this it's crossed
my mind
I really hope that Christopher Steele
doesn't end up accidentally stabbing
himself in the back ten times or falling
off of a tall building or something like
that because we know that those things
can sometimes happen to people that are
involved in this type of thing Trump has
personally attacked Christopher Steele
saying that the report on the Kremlin
connection which was authored by him was
a quote fabricated work put together by
a quote failed spy of course all of that
is completely bogus Christopher Steele a
highly highly respected former mi6
operative he ended up leading to or
rather I guess we could say it in a
different way Michael Flynn Donald
Trump's now former national security
adviser ended up having to resign
shame less than a month into the Donald
Trump administration because he was
covering up Russia connections the
brand-new Attorney General Jeff Sessions
is facing calls for his resignation
because he was covering up conversations
that he had with the Russian ambassador
for the Minnesota senator Al Franken as
I told you earlier in the program now
saying he believes Jeff Sessions
committed perjury and Donald Trump's
former campaign manager Paul Manafort
also had to resign during the campaign
because of shady Russian connections and
possibly illegal payments that he had
received a well-respected former spy
puts together a dossier containing a
series of very disturbing allegations
about trumps Russia connections many of
the allegations are as yet unproven but
we've talked about it before Pat and
will keep talking about it we now have
numerous details of that dossier that
have been corroborated the urine fetish
stuff that was in that dossier that's
not been corroborated so far that is
true
but you can't write it off as fabricated
because numerous elements of it have now
been independently corroborated it's
gotten to a point where even the Senate
Intelligence Committee which is of
course led by Republicans and Chairman
Richard Burr they're going to have to
reach out to people like Christopher
Steele and actually conduct a legitimate
investigation into this because
otherwise there's going to be so much
political repercussions if they don't
and the American people are going to
want their head yeah at a certain point
it's sort of like listen if you really
don't have anything to hide it just
allow the investigation to happen it's
the same thing with the Trump taxes at
this point given that 3/4 of Americans
want to see them if there really wasn't
anything damaging there just let people
see them and put put the story to bed
the only reason you wouldn't is if you
believe that it would actually backfire
and make the situation even worse which
it probably would from for many
reasonable estimates Gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates
or late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s